the tar our National Liberation Army on
patrol the armed wing of the palin
stated Liberation Front is thought to be
at least a thousand five hundred strong
it was founded in 1992 to fight for more
autonomy for the palau minority in shan
state they're one of several prominent
ethnic armed groups that didn't sign a
ceasefire agreement with the Myanmar
government four years ago various ethnic
armed groups here are being targeted
after they attacked a Myanmar Army
Academy in other buildings last month
that's despite unilateral ceasefire
announcements by both sides in the past
few months if we are making a ceasefire
there must be a monitoring team and who
is going to act as a mediator we suggest
a mediator be a member of the political
negotiation team or from China the
Myanmar military told local media in
September that the attacks by the ethnic
armed groups suggest they're not
interested in peace civilians are
bearing the brunt of the violence here
in Namsan township more than 2,000
people have been forced to seek shelter
in neighboring villages and monasteries
camión has high blood pressure and
diabetes the fighting is taking a toll
on her health King didn't at LaMacchia a
little prayer I was frightened I was at
I'm praying praying to the spirits for
safety a bullet has no family and no
relatives a bullet goes straight and
doesn't waver I'm afraid of both sides
of both armies your brand items your is
yonder door yeah but for some the
conflict has made them take up arms
young yet says she became a soldier
after her brother was killed by Myanmar
security forces Pina Eddy
company ray we suffer more oppression
than men with abuse like rape that does
not happen to the males who are able to
defend themselves to prevent these cases
of abuse we become soldiers to defend
ourselves and what a couple barely
buried in Eddy de villages can expect to
be caught in the crossfire
until peace is achieved between ethnic
groups and me on los army Florence Louie
al-jazeera